où est-ce que tu habites chez
moi et où c'est chez toi très loin et où
c'est très loin très loin c'est à
Paris j'étais travail avec ma maman et
où tu que tu as été travaillé avec ta
maman très loin avec avec un buste un
buste tu as pris le buste pour aller et
et qu'est-ce que c'est le travail de ta
maman
écrit ah c'est c'est bien et papa elle
parle elle parle et elle écrit c'est un
très très beau métier et ça te plairait
quand tu serais grande de te marier avec
Michel delpèche ah
non pourquoi parce que j'ai pas envie
c'est c'est des gros mots et c'est
cochons le mariage c'est
cochon qu'est-ce qui est cochon dans le
mariage c'est cochon parce qu'il faut
pas faire ça c'est gros mot oui tu as
bien raison